hello squad hey hello Canada yeah hello
Canada loves you I heard well once you
put up the survey
there's no survey we're not doing so I
understand to understand what it means
to be blind and to live this way that
you guys went through a boot camp but
you were walking around for two weeks
with like sleep shades see how things
just get caught up as well thick shades
I'm just more out there
I like wonder what Daniel there I did
not want around for two weeks okay
that's a great idea but you know we all
were a part of it Apple Frances the
whole idea of like and our producers to
have quite a bit of time to come in and
obviously learn and have professionals
teach us and yeah I was amazing because
it's just I think it really yeah is a
huge bond because we're all going
through it rolled learning do this even
though we can never experience what it's
truly like to be blind feels like it
kind of helped us yeah and I think
everyone had to kind of drop their I
don't know ego or something in a way
because it's it's a world that like
we're all not uncomfortable and big you
know it's a new thing that you have to
really kind of understand and you want
to portray and in a respectable way and
so yeah it was really your fear
literally on a table so comfortable I'm
messing with you
um so this show is already getting
compared to Game of Thrones for health
because it's not even there - you can't
compare no but you only compare their
two worlds that you never went to these
worlds before yeah yeah Game of Thrones
broke through and did that you'll do the
same
they're not even remotely alike so it's
just the only same thing as me and I'm
not even Drogo didn't even get here
fight like I mean non-stop fights in
this like yeah Baba was is a difference
yeah it's listening so the only
similarity as I'm in both
they're not alike but you know the
fandom of that show God and the way that
people are talking about this show yeah
does that make you nervous when people
get that excited about something now you
have no shoes on you can't be
comfortable do you do you know and you
can are you know I usually fandom but
you know you uncomfortable Jason
uncomfortable okay yeah you know people
will like the show hopefully they'll
watch it yes and I you know I've got
good faith in it yeah that's that's
where I'm at
it's a beautiful world it's a story that
we can all connect to and I think
there's a lot of things if we were to
hypothetically have a something that
happened were given was removed what
would happen and it's a neat special
idea and it kind of just what's really
neat is that it's a you know wolves and
bears are higher than us yeah because
they can hunt us down you know I'm
saying so it's just we're back to yeah
an equal playing field and that's just
scary it's just like you were asleep
shading the one around for two weeks
it's hard I was out there by myself in
the cold for two weeks wine
Vancouver I mean we all really you know
far for you Jason you know it was it's
true